a movie with creepy kids and haunting
demons what more would we want around
Halloween set maybe a movie with a
little bit of relevance Paranormal
Activity for of course there has to be a
fourth one because studio mindset says
there has to be a fourth one right so
this review is going to be a story it's
the story of a scary movie that had the
misfortune of coming out in theaters one
week after the creepiest movie I have
seen since the first Paranormal Activity
movie yeah it sucks to be Paranormal
Activity for right now so you know the
Paranormal Activity movies by now I mean
found-footage movies are haunting in a
house at demons terrorizing a family so
someone in the family gets wise to the
action starts putting cameras and
everywhere and so now we get to see some
paranormal activity and in this movie
the one who gets wise to the act is this
15 year old girl and her boyfriend and I
will say this the boyfriend was awesome
I felt like this dude carried the entire
movie he was funny he was witty he was
relatable I like that dude I thought the
little chick would annoy me in this
movie she really didn't she holds her
own just fine but it really it's all
about the boyfriend dude was hilarious
so now yeah Paranormal Activity 4 same
different day
I mean the first Paranormal Activity
movie left its mark on cinema you know
it revitalizes the whole found-footage
genre there have been so many found
footage movies that have come out after
Paranormal Activity it's not even funny
the problem was something like this by
the time you get to the fourth movie
we've all seen it before Paranormal
Activity one was really shocking it's
like dude I've never seen a movie that
holds you that kind of anxiety and feels
that real I thought that was really cool
was it exciting no but it was creepy as
the next two movies did a good job
at holding to that tradition I thought
the third one was the flashiest one you
know I mean furniture and shits getting
thrown everywhere I'm like that's not
creepy but that's cool as I and
Paranormal Activity 4 they try to throw
a couple new things in there but in the
end you're like I've seen this before
it's like nothing in Paranormal Activity
4 it is as flashy as it wasn't 3 or as
intense and creepy as it wasn't 1 it's
just this movie that's in the middle you
know it's just graze on real like oh
yeah you're trying but everything in 4
is like the grade-b version of
everything they've already done in 1 2
and 3 only they did it better in 1 2 & 3
95% of the that makes you in this
movie jump-scare there's one scene where
it's a still shot nothing's happening
don't happens oh it was the cat jumping
on the computer right there I was like
okay I know where this movie's going I
don't get all spoiler ish on you or
anything like that but there were a
couple things that happened near the end
of the movie where I was like whoa that
was dead that was creepy that was
quickly over it movie ends you walk out
to your carts pitch black out it's not
phased you at all actually I take that
back I was kind of creeped out because I
was still thinking of that creeper from
sinister I felt like paranormal activity
for tried too hard to be Paranormal
Activity remember the scene in
Paranormal Activity one they're both in
bed it's nighttime didn't you hear that
demon just go BAM and just hit the wall
that scene made my hair stand up I was
like that was some and it is
genuinely scarier than any paranormal
activity for little kids silhouette and
night vision that this movie can muster
in a franchise like Paranormal Activity
we've seen it all by the third movie
which brings up a point they could have
stopped at 3 it could have been the
Paranormal Activity trilogy it could
have been a really good legacy for a
studio to leave it would have been a
Halloween tradition for a lot of people
to watch the Paranormal Activity trilogy
would have been good right even but now
we have four and by the end of four
there's no indication this is gonna be
the end which means we're gonna get five
and six probably one of them in 3d so
the Paranormal Activity four have a
couple of creepy moments it did
genuinely scary not at all had a lot of
jump scares it's a jump scare Fiesta but
what do you really expect from a scary
movie franchise that has gone to four I
would say Paranormal Activity 4 would be
a good time if you're drunk
yeah and knows a party are you gonna go
take a shot every time there's a jump
scare yeah you'll be trashed by halfway
through the movie right so Halloween's
coming up so what are you gonna do for
Halloween what are you gonna dress as
whatever you're doing comment below let
me know me I would tell you but I'm not
going to yet follow me on Twitter there
will probably be a couple of pictures
hopefully not incriminating once not
weird from a video again and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you
[Music]